Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to "West of Loathing".
Now that I've got my mind's eye opened...
I figured, "It's time to go to Madness Maw Mine, and figure out what the hell is happening over there", because - WHOA
"Starts making a bleeper?"
It's not an encounter...(reads text) "Involuntary risk-taking is rewarded when you find a hi-tech crate"
Okay?
(surprised Markimoo)
I got punch cards!
I don't know what that means, but I got them! I got one of those before, but I'm not under the- Hi
How'zit going there, friendo?
What are you doing? What's up here, partner?
(reads dialogue)
Right, sure!
(keeps reading dialogue)
I'm gonna hornswaggle ya!
If you know what I mean ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) (Me: Mark really?)
(keeps reading dialogue)
Alrighty then...Well, that worked out mothfully well (Me:what?)
Mouthfully well
It worked out mouthfully well (Me: seriously what the hell, Mark?)
I'm gonna get Foragin', so I can get this Goddamn loco weed!
Got it!
Nailed it!
(surprised) Ooh, green thumb!
Yayyy! (Markichild in action)
Yayyyyy
I got a green thumb now!
I dunno- Oh (softly)Hi
Hello, cultist, hello!
(reads dialogue)
I...forgot it!
Anyway...
(reads in-game dialogue)
Eeyup, eeyup.
Oh?
(reads text)
"They're mine, don't TOUCH THEM." Alright, fine then!
(moar dialogue...I'm not gonna bore you with this)
It sounded like a threat, when he said it like that.
Okay, say, I'll see ya.
If I wouldn't ask
Why'S your Mask Difference Because i'm the leader of the Cell how Can you be Down Here and now know that
Look I Passed seven Different Guys to get here Obviously if I weren't meant to be here that Would be Impossible I suppose
So These Master, everyone's Talking About a great Dark Master Roberto are You sure you're Supposed
To be down here Sure sure it's fine it's Fine don't worry about don't worry but man hi Isaac
Listen to what
Master of Course Can't you hear him, yeah sure Sure Can
I sure can so I remember These Spirals in Another mind
It Says dear jeff The Big Guy Says to stay out here Praise be Roberto Sincerely
Jeff
My Name is dev
Name is you I'll fry Bread, over The fine Bounder Goes Crazy when you go near this Rock, okay?
Well There's A ladder there let's go Down
Okay, cha, know. Cha. Cha, cha, Know There are Four Buttons
Some fuck Row
Sums at Bundy Volcanic Al machine Machine
so you stick Him in the Slop and
Something Happens
I don't know what's going on Sure okay why not big Cylinder I got an L
Vibratos Cylinder All right a bunch of Paper Cards all right
and they Had a bunch of Rocks
All Right I don't know what's going on here but I'm gonna get out of here I'm Gonna go to the Buffalo Pile
Here it's Crazy hot out of here the deserts the worst you Could end up like one of Those Charred Black
Skeletons Clacking Towards You i'll fight him I'll give Him a little Fight a shootin an Eat up
Some of Them you hit None of them got them, asshole all right fine
to Fish you a fuck
Get Carried, oh
Hot God Poins my skin, Bang that's not Enough you Finish out that one
Damn it Gary White got be Better than me Bang if my Shooting Nanny Would have hit One of Them it Would have Been Better
Got a Gold Tooth Though so that's good i can give it to that way, oh?
Gosh Lord of Bones that is die iT's a lot of Bones
It's a lot of Bones wow wow wow what is it Appears to be a giant Pile of Buffalo skeletons why?
I don't know Guess Beats Leaving them Strewn all over Everywhere that Is
That's A lot of Bones
That's A lot of Bones okay alright Buffalo Buffalo Buffalo Buffalo Buffalo Buffalo
Wow alright, well This Seems Culty I mean I'm not Just Called Names here but this big Ol P
Duck-Sized Skeleton Gross Excise, Hippopotamus gross Cruise, Fieri I'm Still in Stalker
Alright Well There's A lot of Those?
Here A lot of Activity Down That Corridor Chanting Shuffling of Robes Scattering of Bones Scary Stuff you really, Shouldn't go Down There alright
Okay, alright what's down here, oh?
It's covered in Big Beakers I got an Oversized Chemical Bigger Gallon Size Alright cool
Blah
Great Blood You have no idea what you're trying to Make are you sure you want to mess with this Stuff
Yeah
Give it up me Open up the blood Faucet and Fill the Beaker up Halfway Milk
Less Threatening Than the Blood go with the Milk alright Partially fill acre gets Give Me some Attacker just Watch this Shit
Steam Rises From the Beaker Is in Reaction
Intensifies The Intense Heat of the Reaction Fuses the ekor spigot Into A useless mass of Metal how will it end
The Box and What's Left in The Beaker is yes Tell me Tom
When the Reaction subside you're Left With a beaker of A revolting Black Fluid and what's even Worse
Is that it's Useless revolting Black Fluid you pour it Down the Floor Train before it Can Disappoint you can be Further
And then Discard the beaker Take that black Fluid ha Showed you what's up wait
Hang on Wait, oh god Damn it I just Came from that Corridor Didn't I
Wait I want to go back, oh?
I want to go back Wait Through the Bars Hundreds of Buffalo Human Skeleton Hybrids I wanted to Make Milk Milk Lemonade
Round the Corner Fudge is Made that's what I wanted to do I forgot about
Would Have Made Fudge I know it Would have made Fudge it Would have a guaranteed Flush it's good toilet
It Really Should use Scented Candles yeah sure Tell them that when you find him?
All right wait, oh?
Got a Discipline Slip what's that Looks like
One of the necromancer Cultus got written up two more of These and They'll be Ritually
Eviscerated Nothing personal it Says Corporate Policy all right fine then, well that's weird?
All Right Bones Rule do They
okay
All right
cool
Hi Is that Gonna Help me Blend in
Hide in if you Settle it amongst the Thick black Robes it's Pretty Comfortable Wait
You Wait and Wait you Finally hear some Noises Outside There's A couple cultists Pass Through on Their Way from somewhere else you?
Don't Catch much what they Say but what you do here Is anchor after Blood way to go Stud
Why is drew Doug Having so much trouble With This Wait some more Occur after blood you Say Wait some More
You wait a while longer in the Cult Is passed Through again this Time you
Over Here Something Different no Remember the rhyme Milk after Blood Rituals A died
Hmm no capture Blood rituals at A dud Occur after Blood, okay A car after blood way to go Stud
Milk its Milk before Blood jool is good luck why
Can't you get This Probably because it doesn't rhyme okay so it's Milk
Blood iker Milk Blood Occur that's what it does that's how I go no no doug that's not it Remember Blood for milk Is as
Obsolete as the Word Filk
That's Kinda What Stretch
So it's Milk Lyde Milk Bloody ker got it blood before Akers start That soldiers Ticker
oh Fundamentals of Nextmax Gives you the raise skeletal Buddy that sounds Bad why, Would I do that
oh
do I have enough to Lock-Picking, oh
No I don't okay fine ah
I'm back here all right so wait Yeah I really want to Make I want to See if Milk Milk Lemonade?
Milk Milk Lemonade
What's the Reaction Steam Cause the lemonade Faucet to get Clogged up how will it end The Boiling subsides was Left in the Beaker Is
Fudge
That's so good that's so good
23:23
Give Me Bad Fudge
You Dumped the entire Beaker of Fudge in your Mouth and Revel in it Fudge Mental, oh my god that's Amazing
Milk Milk Lemonade Milk okay, yeah Wait Look another Beaker
Milk Blood
Occur
Few Chablis One No
Wait
No wait no wait why is it clogged up?
Why is it Fused Shut no Milk Boy Dicker
Then I goof it I goofed it Didn't I i goofed it real bad oh, no
At least I got my Fudge that's why, I can be happy about uh fine what's down here then, Is slab alone
Could Let Some Alice Doyle's do it what's going on here what, oh, loses Scale, we?
Go, They Get Their Tough - all right, well I'm gonna put This in my Body?
All Right I'm Gonna Shoot Them Bang
Bitch
Bang
Gary, okay good Bang Bang whomp it's all right you Gonna get Shot
Mmm not doubt you'll be Effect I must Shoot you you lumps
Yeah Gary got, him up what gear Dude
Bang
Let's Help that Cousin, Guy Can I shoot that Guy
But I gotta go in Mono e Mono ray Romano I fine I'm Going in Manual
God dammit Why not Stick With being A god Damn
Sure why am I not a bean Slinger that's my question, Always it's a farming Thing
Alright fine man how do I clean the Goddamn thing I know I got to do that ah Reading Material
Yes that's me Whoo I can get good medicine Let's You Recover hp Ink
on Big Spleen more Potions in a day Expert Poisoner
Hmm I'll Take Big Spleen that sounds good i like my spleen your
Chemical Experimentations Have given you a Comically, Oversized spleen trust me
All right so how do I clean this Shit There's no way to clean it what if I just mess up
Everything and I Accidentally like but if I what if I just Absolutely
Bungle Up Everything all right here We go?
Disgusting Tainted Blood all right What about Milk Milk Milk
We're Just gonna go super Milk I don't know how this is gonna ruin it but Let's ruin it then melts it for some Reason
Surprisingly After The Reaction Concludes you're Left with A big Beaker full of Milk
It's pretty Anti-Climatic and Now all These are Fused Shut, well what good Golly Gosh
Is that Gonna do me how do I clean that
Alright fine you know what I'm gonna get out of There I'll come back Later
Alright I gotta go, oh?
Yeah I gotta go to the desert House I Forgot I know this is Shifting gears Right now but I got to go back to
The desert House and See, oh Cheap wine all right
Well That's good Anyway not Worried about that I got to go back to the desert House and See if um
If I boil up this thing Maybe i can do something about it besides Killing them all
Be nice Because I really, don't know how to get this all done
Oil the hinges
Oil Them you use last of the oil in the can on the rusty hinges the gates will open Easily and Silently
Nice
Alright You Creep Up to the door you Can hear the gang inside you notice the door Jamb is busted prod from being Kicked in
There's A crude
Hasc Made of Bent Nails
Looks Like The Bandits Impotence Just Been Locking it with a padlock from the outside When they leave if you
Had A lock you could turn This Fortress Into a Prison
And Let me go to dirt Wather I know There was A lock available Somewhere who wants to fight?
Well your dead-Bang
Wants The Fight Know About are you dead alright so if I go in here I
Know There's someone That's Selling A lock and if I get a lock on that but Boy
What's it Gonna do for me not you yes Coz, was it you?
Buttonwillow
What are you Buttonwillow Corpse of the Cowboy oh Proper burial alright what do you got you got a lock
No Where's your Goddamn way I know There, was A lock alright I'll come back to that ok I gotta go to curious Cops
Open it and Four Nails Ranch Punch Great right, we're Going to curious Cops I don't even Know A
Lot of Trees Here
Looking at all These Trees
You'd have to if There's Nothing Else to look at it and Get A be Leaping Box Shooting to bring Us here let's go Down
A bit oh
Well vibrate, oh
Alright Sneaking on my Belly Just to make Sure no trees Sneaked up on me
Oh, Hello Shock, Weed Plant got Shock Weed extract all right Sure why not whoa, hello?
Looks Pretty Tough and Pretty Attentive Alright Alright not that Tough, I'm A one Shot this Bad Boy Watch This
Alright Fine then you're dead now so what good with that oh Deafening Whoa
Yay, Jumping for Joy, wow that's A big Teleporter
Machine Is not Switched on but as an empty coffee Cup
Confounded Contraption Is Dark and Silent the Monolith is dark
Teresting that's a big-ass Teleporter that. Is that is A big
Teleported Like A big way Big way Big Teleporter I got to go back to the Professor
Eventually but Let Me hit This Mold Military send Cemetery ooh
Crack of a rifle
Let, Bee Buzzes Past your ear I call Bullets Let be Sometimes aah
Let's Fight him Hey Buddy hey Buddy I just died ok, well that was fun antique range Fighter
Oh, nice wow I want that, oh?
My Thing on my thing this Is my third eye Still open by the way yes it is yes it is all right
Military simile, oh
Military, oh, no that is Embarrassing all right it's your Partner Look Through A
Gate Many of Stone Crosses Those are Graves I guess Military Grave Since They're all the Same and in Such neat Rows
Soldiers Yeah even When, They're Dead the officers Make them line UP in Formation
Funny all Right There's a shovel I don't need Another Shovel Keep up ground in the Shed the Caretaker Appears to have Been Shirking his
Duties for Quite A
While Judging by the Dust and Cobwebs Look at the tools all right Shovel under the chair all right Let's go about the
Desk all right Tiny Paint Jars all right Flyers
for Memoriam, oh
Okay, well Alright Then eternal Flame wow?
There's an Eternal Flame Here this is a Burning unser no Flame
I'm Pretty sure You're not supposed to do that no it's good fire not to wasting it let Gary
Handle This Gary Ambles over and chats With the goblin all right hey
They Asking if One inquire, We need all right sure I'll Buy a Weenie, oh?
I don't want to trade off my moxie For that no thanks no thanks buck, oh no thanks Buckaroo
Fuckery bear Get out of here With you stupid, oh wow you can
Visit an Individual Plot Number I need to visit 420 That's right blaze it ooh
Okay, stop Looting Graves That no for one day We'll stop for now Passing Fair mycologist
Bush After you'd finished Reading the book you
Absent-Mindedly Misplace it While Musing about Mushrooms drat I'm so stupid all right now that
We did that I think I need to go back to the ghost Wood because i i didn't finish this, oh?
All right I'll show you hey I drink This real Quick Guys Are good, okay Time for Bangs
okay, Welp See ya
Intimidating Six-gun I don't need that if I was still a cowpuncher that might be good for me hey need a drink Please
Beer Please
Bumper Dank, mum Fleur but now my Middle Name is Sneaky it's Sneaky I'll Buy it
Got a Bottle of Goes, Beer it's cold
All right, well I got that why?
Should I have that I forgot why, I needed a, beer was There Anything Else I've Completely Forgotten
Yes that was it I just Came for a Cup Bottle of Goes Beer that was Literally it, well that was fun?
Let me go back to Bread Would See if I can solve some of Their Problems Whoo Curious abandon Wall Damned
Well Stopped who investigated all right ah?
Peculiar Hearing A tiny Sound like A Distant, High-Pitched Humming me too, aha, A, well A, well if sounds where Water is not
Seem to be Coming Down There the Transponder Goes all right, well I'll go down, oh?
Look at you where am I going now
Fairly Nowhere Because everything's Dead all right, well don't know Where this Taking me
Whoo-Hoo Vibrate, oh chamber
Habu no Statues Masoom no Buttons put in Large Crunch Card, okay
Whoa put in Punch Card, oh yeah put in Punch Card, oh yeah, okay cool
But I'm Learning Words
That's Good ooh
I had A lot of These Punch Cards okay, well I've Learned A lot of Things
Hibou No terminal all right then
Well I i there's a hobo no terminal?
Huh it's Amazing That These Teleporters Still Have power to him but Nothing Else Seems as it does all right
Well That's good a little bit of A Detour on the Way back to brad Wood so let's Keep on Going
Well Time to Shoot Somebody yeah Gonna Shoot you Buying, okay, you're dead Now Thank you Vibrations Capulin
Scapula all right Thank you Redwood, hey I took Care of your Mail Problem
all
Right, well I'll Take Care of all your Problems then all right Let, me Just Look at all your Problems the logging Permit
We're Running out of Trees Around here that's not good for my bridge the town died
Okay, I guess I'll Check that out, oh that's why, I need to go to the dead ghost Wood
okay
Well Let me Just get all of his Problems lined Up and that way i can Just
Freakin do the Thing yet Soup Shortage Sure, well Bread Would Bread bowls, ah soup Stuck load
Great That's Where I wanted to go skeleton raids that's Bad two more all right
Oh mutts!
Brewery do I really Gotta solve all your Damn Problems Old man all right last One Missing Bread I got all of it Baker Boys
Sure Thing, we're Going to al's and your Ranch first
Then we're Gonna go the rest of the Way open it up good sweet, ah
Hello
Cows Hearing Us I'm Pretty Sure the cows can See us let, alone Hear Us all right Let's find him
Got to Jump on him this Time, oh these Guys Ain't Gonna get Nothing don't Shoot him Up
Shoot A marine
I'm so sorry about that cows
But it's too, Late for you Time for you to go home wow this place Have Really, Been Blown to pieces
Alright Diary of Alexandria Alexandria good cool Name ooh
You Flip Through the Diary most of it Is uneventful
Describing the life of A woman who likes books it isn't interested in much else it ends With the Passage About a soldier from A
Nearby Forewarning Or About some Kind of danger he
Wouldn't Specify so she moved Most of her Valuable Books to the Cellar?
It took the Ordinary Precautions Boarding up the Windows and not Leaving the House at night it Turns out that isn't much good against Can
Lose all right Overdue Bread Would Book, well found that one?
12.5 Percent of toast, oh modern snake Oiler Thank you I needed that, one all right Bad medicine Quick on the draw Increasing your Speed
Expert Poisoner I'll be quick on the draw that sounds good
All right yeah I Didn't even Read how they Lost that one and it was Probably Gonna Make me Mad
Alright you pick up the Campbell and inspected There's an Inscription that you Can Mostly Read it Says the Cannibal Came for for Treason and
It'S in duress Stamp Around the surface
This Bombardment, was done By the Army at fort Treason, well that sounds Bad how do I open This Goddamn Cellar
Hopefully She's There all right, well I got that
So let me go, over to fort Trees and See if I can get some answers out of These assholes, oh?
Shut Up
Bam Alright You're Dead Alright I'm Really, Really Tough that that like that that Potion
That Really did it in for me for man's They do not answering
Yes to Scavenge all right Let's go Scavenge
Oh you!
Look at the Cannon to find kam
Demi Culverin in Size and sir your Cannonball
You Look Through the rangefinder on the Cannon but you can't See Any Indication of Anything you want to Shoot at you Decide Not to
waste the ball
Alright What Arrow With your Wastefulness Jeez
Coward
All right what, do We got ever Soldier man Is gone Poke Around See if I Can find something what, do We got Here?
All right sugar Guns Eye Candy okay all right Lock-Picking all right Kick open all right Military School class ring
That's A Lot of Pistol damage
All Right Good stuff that's A lot of Silver Bullets, oh private Matthews diary all right what
Do We got there Wait Where'd They go, oh There it is okay?
Most of private Math Oz diaries empty Places inc sprott Latrine Duty
Stuck out in The Middle of Nowhere our Captive as they Decided Nearby ranch was Actually an Enemy Spy Outpost Felt Compelled to?
Warn the woman oh?
okay
This doesn't Have Any Damn sure what the, hell Sure Leaving Dirt Water
Weird
Claire's is Intention to start a mutiny but the Dairy ends With no Conclusion to the story
Interesting private Lemmons Diary all right private Lemmons Diaries Pretty dry and not very Interesting Day-To-Day Duties
Captain Simon Becoming Increasingly Agitated and Convinced that a nearby ranch is being used as a spy Outpost Lema
Doesn't Sound Convinced but Annoy orders are Orders
Descending the Ranks Possible Mutiny Rest of the Pages Are Blank was There Anybody Else's?
No but I get this where did that come from all right I'll do Expert Poisoner nice, oh
When you Apply Poison you flat Three Times that much
Importantly You get so Distracted about Thinking the new Kinds of Poison that you Misplace a magazine
Ah Boring I should Probably Change out for One of These rings
All right This is good i mean I do Love my nasty Spittoon ring but
You know, it's a good Trade-off I suppose must have been Where they stored all the fire
Funny Funny Stuff Buddy Funny Stuff Buddy Poo all right Let's Quickly go, over to the Old Schmaltz Bull rory
Jump in and See, oh nice okay
What's over here Smalls What's here Buddy a smell what is it a Brewery the Goblins Have
Beer Beer oh booze, we de Fermenting the special Cactus Juice is it good can't ever Remembering
okay
Be right back See you Guys Have fun with that I'm gonna Get a floral ring
Mmm that's right Makes Foraging Random Encounters much more Likely
Oh that's so nice okay all right Now Let's See if There's A yeah that's Fucking Terrifying, okay Now I'm gonna Just uh?
Yeah here We go see what hey?
How's it Going Fellas Too Scared to talk to you just Totally Freaked out About the yeast, Beer Hose
You're Not Really Sure what Purpose it must have served all right, well sample These Contents it's Almost Pure Ethanol Blargh
Oh, dead Guy's hat got Knocked. Off it's covered With yeast, okay?
Okay, but, oh great
This is great at
Aware of you and your loved Ones Absolutely love the Smell of Dough if You don't mind it in your Enemies Hate it I guess
Alrighty then wow
The Yeast B Seems to have Killed This Guy Pretty Thoroughly
So I've got a crazy Sponsors Barely broken
Loose From The Vats and Even Some of the Bandits I guess They've Brewed up something they
Couldn't put Down They Can Barley Control it you'll have to hop too if you want to prevail
All Right fine then all right We got the Jump on him Big Boy?
Got the Jump on Him Baby right yeah Bam and then Boom, oh Shit dude Right well
Out Bang dad I Should have Gotten The hard hat This is Pretty Easy
Alright The Remains of the Horrible beast I guess you could Take some back to the Mayor it's Probably Still good right I got A
Big Old Glob of Yeast
Just Right in The Backpack no Container Half A ton of Yeast
Great This whole Yeast Theft Biz doesn't Seem to have gone too
Well for you Boys yeah?
Jeez are you Bounty hunter Relax the Mayor Just wants his yeast Back he Didn't Say Anything About Hauling you in Huh at least
Okay, well the yeast Is in That Revolting trial what Happened?
Well We got Bored of Bread Is all and Know A bit About Brewing and We Figured if We Came back with A couple kegs
And Nobody Would mind if We stole that yeast, no offense but it seems like you are much of a brewer hey
Well ideally you wouldn't end Up with a ravenous yeast Monster?
Wasn't my okay was my fault I understand what happens the bats Are Old We Didn't Clean them Properly First I think There were some
Frogs Living in One of Them and You Figured you could use the extra hops ha
Ha ha if You're Sure you've Figured it got it Figured out you Could set up Shop in dirt Water
Oh yeah!
It's Turning Into Quite a little Metropolis I'D love to have my own place I'll go Check it out alright Three Cans
Beer Can of Schmaltz Blue-Ribbon
All Right that's A lot of damage that's A lot of extra damage I don't know if I can
Imbibe that I think I'm Pretty Full but
Maybe Actually my liver Can Take A good bit Up drink some of that hmm, hmm, we Can lukewarm great
Fun stuff good stuff glad I did That beer Hose
All Right hey it's Too Grumpy to talk to you
Arrest Him You're Under Arrest for what Stealing About Two handfuls of east yes and the Sentence for that
Is what About Three Days in Jail and Brentwood Does not Actually have a jail all right I'll let you off with a Warning
What About this dead Guy, yep he's Dead all right, Well that'll do it for this Episode
Well we're Knockin this List off Pretty Quick all These Problems Seem to not be doing too bad for me
So either Way Thank you everybody so much for Watching God I love this game Let me Know
We think Down The Comments Below and as always I will see you in the next Video?